me
can you hear me
okay great yeah so it's a pleasure and
honor to be uh
moderating that's all i'm going to be
doing up here is moderating this
committee you guys are going to do all
the speaking and all the questions and
so on uh it's it's actually really great
to uh see you all here i i just live up
in the hills of berkeley so this is like
a
short trip down the the road for me so
it's it's a lot of fun
uh just in terms of starting out i think
we're going to start out by everybody
just spending like two or three four
minutes uh introducing everybody
although i'm sure everybody and just
saying a little bit about why we're here
um i i do have a a it's kind of a silly
but kind of interesting perspective
about how i think about things in terms
of companies and so on i think of a
company as kind of being like an
organism
and and it has to enact in this
environment and it can be a very rough
environment if it doesn't act correctly
it's going to die
and so there's all kinds of different
organisms and so it's kind of
interesting for me to put the
perspective of the questions we're going
to be addressing today into that context
about there's different kind of
organizations some of you working large
organizations that were started by
others and you're doing a research kind
of
activity within organizations other
views have a deep theoretical you know
all of you have a deep theoretical
background and so on but you started
your own company and so the whole
genesis of the company starts from this
kind of theoretical background so i
think they're kind of
and then over time you notice that
companies who
start one way over time as they evolve
and they they kind of sell their
products into the market and and so on
they they evolve and it completely
changes in terms of what they need i
remember in the early days
akamai had this uh which is one of those
companies that start from a theoretical
background had a huge contingent of
theoretical researchers uh working in it
and then
very pretty quickly they kind of
downsized that quite a bit because they
really had to focus on actually getting
out there and and that kind of evolution
is something i think it's also
interesting to kind of understand and
discuss
so with that i'm going to please
go ahead and introduce yourselves
thanks thanks mike oh can you hear me
can you hear me now great thanks thanks
to shafi and mike for
inviting me to this panel so i'm ravi i
work at google research in mountain view
so i've been in industry for my entire
career for the last 20 24 years
uh first ibm and then yahoo and now at
google for the last almost 10 years
uh so
shafi has given a bunch of questions
that i would like to answer
that that will make it easy so do
companies industries uh under understand
the value of basic research so the
answer is a little bit more nuanced
um
the answer is not fixed over time so it
really depends on the company and the
time you're talking about
luckily for us at this point in time i
think many companies do understand the
value of research especially theoretical
research so we are in a lucky phase in
you know times
so does working in company industry
enable you to do basic research yes
definitely enables to do basic research
and has it all as it altered your view
of what's important
again the answer is a little bit more
subtle because
it's not what's important it's more like
what things will actually work in
practice
so as theoreticians we tend to look at a
lot of problems from different angles
many of them have certain solutions that
we all like
but only some of them actually tend to
be
applicable in practice and working in a
company definitely opens that vision a
little bit more i feel
so how can we better feed
how can we do better feeding off each
other
uh so i think that's a very simple uh
answer to this question this is the next
one which is help us raise our salaries
so
i strongly encourage faculty to come and
spend time in industry you know the many
companies including google have
extensive programs where
faculty can come and spend a year or two
either or
part-time visiting bases or full-time
basis i strongly encourage faculty to
academics to come and spend time in
industry
and what is it like to have a boss again
it depends on the boss actually luckily
i've had great bosses i still have uh
excellent bosses so
that's the easy answer for me thank you
hi i'm battalion thanks ravi for
answering the questions uh i i thought
we would maybe discuss some of them uh
again and in a more detailed way but uh
just
uh
yeah i'm vitaly i've worked on i work on
foundations of machine learning and
privacy preserving data analysis i'm now
at apple in a group with canal and also
pariksit who just
joined like a month ago
i've worked also my entire not so not as
long career uh
in industry i was at ibm for 10 years
then at uh google
brain for a couple of years and now i'm
at apple
uh since we're talking about the theory
and industry uh let me just very briefly
like tell you about these groups the
first one was at ibm
which which was a theory group here uh i
mean ibm alberta and san jose it's sort
of for one can think of it as an old
school uh theory group uh
many people have spent time there and
had very illustrious uh sort of uh
history with uh
many great people going uh spending time
there
uh it sort of has this had this model
where they bring in theoreticians to
work on whatever they like and then
hope to create some kind of incentives
uh so that some sort of impact will come
out for the uh for the company without
sort of setting specific expectations
they certainly had the many
great success stories but maybe also not
uh there was no systematic way about
creating these success stories and maybe
over time it wasn't the best model it
seems so then i spent some time at the
google brain after uh they started this
very strong push into
deep learning and machine learning and
investment in this area in hope to
attract researchers and create i mean
they of course recognize the importance
of machine learning for for the company
um
and i think this was a certainly much
more successful model with a lot of
interactions and our group has uh
created some some
learning algorithms that ended up being
used in production
we also worked on privacy and this is
kind of an area which uh
i start started liking thanks to my
great colleague kunal
google maybe wasn't investing as heavily
as in privacy
as apple was interested in investing so
more recently we switched to working on
differential privacy
and private data analysis apple where we
sort of i think have maybe the best
model at least in my career so far where
we
help people build tools uh and while
doing this we discover many interesting
problems and understand what sort of is
uh maybe more important and at the same
time we also
i would say
think of problems which we find
interesting which appeal to our gods of
what is going to be
important and interesting in in the
longer term and we just work on those
problems without any connection to the
company and publish that work and engage
with um
academia and um hope to continue doing
this
hope i didn't take too long
[Music]
hi
my name is mariana aikua and i'm
currently a research scientist at google
and i think throughout my career i've
been in many different academic and
industry settings
where i spent my postdoc at ibm watson
and then i was a research scientist at
sri just down here in south bay then i
spent a few years as a faculty at yale
and then i kind of went back to the
industry setting at google
so i think from my perspective
the type of research that i work on and
the kind of questions i'm trying to
solve haven't changed that much
between all of these places where i have
been
maybe the thing that has changed is how
i justify why i do what i do uh and uh
and i think that's
i think maybe my experience my first
experience as a research scientist that
the sri gave me a good training since
this was a place heavily focused on
writing grant proposals and being able
to kind of
succinctly express why you think that
what you want to do is going to be
useful for other people
uh but i would also say that
even before going to to industry i i am
probably a theorist at heart but i like
to dabble in practice and i want to
imagine that what i will do will
eventually be used by somebody so
in that aspect i kind of enjoy the
the closer interaction that
the industry setting gives you as an
opportunity with people from many
different backgrounds uh who don't
necessarily speak the language of theory
but
i think there it offers you an
opportunity to interact with many very
smart people from many different
perspectives
and i think
at google i sit in an organization which
is called privacy safety and security
and it is curious for me because my
research area is cryptography and
somehow there is this interesting
interface between
cryptography privacy security where
practical security systems that exist
nowadays and that are kind of the
backbone of everything that that is
happening on the internet or in our
machines
uh use many
ad hoc techniques that are not provable
security and at the same time we as
cryptographers have been taught that we
really
probable security is the right way to
formalize things and the right way to go
about it
and there is this interface that we sit
on on how do we go between these ad-hoc
things that work in practice and we
really don't want to turn them off
at once and how do we at the same time
kind of communicate the value of
things that come with probable security
and create incentives uh to invest in in
this type of techniques and to invest
even if it comes at some cost whether
this is efficiency cost or like dollar
cost or things along those lines so i
think this is a very interesting
interface and i think it's very hard to
solve
but
i i think also in that aspect is
important to have people who speak both
languages that sit also in industry and
that can act as a translators hopefully
so i think i'll stop with this for now
hello uh
celia mcauley academic
for a long time now turn entrepreneur
and with uh
i'll go on the adventure
so the name of the and i have not
understood exactly sorry i didn't read
my mamo so there were
questions uh i'm prepared perhaps i
should answer i don't know
industries
and this is um
academia for theoretical research in
your case sylvia would like to know who
is your boss
my wife mother
but
no okay so first of all i found actually
is a very cultural and interesting
phenomenon why do we think we had to
debate
this industry right or
discuss but it's so
natural so i think it comes from a deep
sense that we must have we are having so
good as researchers that we say we are a
parasite to society because we are doing
whatever we like and we start wondering
you know we're really relevant so i i
don't understand of course you know
industry uh needs to have research
everybody has another idea like why do
they die so we had to be in continual
evolution or if we stop evolving well
some somebody better than us will
supplant us right to some of our species
so i really think of it uh
and the only difference that i think is
is a larger paradigm between immediate
gratification
and uh postponed gravitation and
everybody knows that postpone
gratification makes you more gratified
however if you respond too much when
it's too too late right so the point is
but
you're not alive to enjoy so
i i think that the
research
can be very much close to in my opinion
research or to be relevant at least
by the way historically we only know
about the research that has been
relevant because everest is not going to
be in the history book nobody knows
about it anymore right so whether you
like it or not
so you're going to be remembered if
you're going to be relevant not
immediately but at some point in time so
how much you want to be
disjoined from water becomes relevant of
it is a really a medical taste i think
but we need to have an equilibrium among
all of our all things among all the
industry where the one
portion of the industry which is really
immediately
attached to research is the startup
because a startup if he keeps on doing
the same thing the regular industry does
it doesn't grow it's going to maybe
suffocate so that is really where i
think that there is a innovation
research and immediate applicability
they are most tied for the rest is an is
unhealthy equilibrium so just you know
don't feel guilty do whatever you want
try to be relevant as much as you want
if you want to be remembered because
that is a this is crucial point and i
think there is nothing to explain it's
not a mystery it's a is a continuum
that's the way i look at it
so what's interesting about what you
said silvio is that
among the folks here you're probably the
only one who's quote unquote in a
startup the one that you started
yeah
that is but my style in research is the
same
so somehow i
i'm
something can tell you know it's usually
i cannot read the paper um because uh i
took it in some audience as mine and
what the notation when i would set up an
audition i get lost right away so it's
much easier for some of us you know he's
a real question of style say you write
your own paper rather than reading it on
paper and figure out what they say and
so um so yeah so i think it is um
it's a matter of taste we are all
welcome here everybody has a different
style and
if you are a particular style the
startup is your right industry the uh or
some other rails is the consulting to an
industry that really want to open to
research is
great it's good to have researchers
inside the industry but remember
everybody's better off better advice to
have actually help from academia because
i really academia thinker is a really
a great place to do uh to industry and
try to figure out what is going on out
there but i i think that you
is so natural but as to say is to say
a pasta and body weight i mean of course
we are related i can
think that there is a way should be a
debate between the recession industry to
me so
so clear but so so maybe the question
though is a little different sylvia
because they've been you're you're
absolutely right
but there's been many cases like xerox
for example where they had a fantastic
research but it was completely divorced
from their commercial and they didn't
transfer across right and so there are
companies that came in there and really
benefited from that for example apple
right but they themselves did not so i
guess the question is a little more
nuanced is how
can you effectively have research into
these companies so they actually can
move the you know be in in in sort of
sync with the company and and at large
and really benefit the company
but also kind of so i'm eager to pass
the microphone to my left but
but in so far you are you ask me so i
mean of course zyrgos is one olivet is
another one you know that the touch
screen was actually done by elevator
before even um apple
i'm italian connection so
so the point is that
companies screw it up very often so very
often they don't understand where the
value is and what the
role in life is and and so i don't
believe it is uh it is partly the effort
of the researchers to go to upper
management say you don't understand that
much value every year it's also the
other way for a manager but it's not
another responsibility for us uh is
aerodynamic sometimes you know people
screw it up and uh in many ways in which
you know they don't communicate right uh
does it ring a bell do you have a spouse
you can communicate enough so it's uh of
course communication is very important
but i don't believe that there is a
crisis is that somebody makes a mistake
once in a while but most of the time we
communicate and we get along and we
improve right
okay let's let's continue and we'll come
back to it okay hi hey i'm yael kalai uh
actually before i start i wanted to say
a huge thank you uh for simon's for this
amazing past 10 years for dick for shafi
for all the amazing support staff
it's been really really wonderful for us
as a community and for me in particular
for the great time i've had here along
the years so thank you
[Applause]
and in terms of my own journey i
actually dabbled a lot about the
question of academia and versus industry
i started off in academia only for one
year and then i moved to microsoft i was
a georgia tech and then i moved to
microsoft research and where i am until
today and in the last six years i was i
also joined as an adjunct professor at
mit so i've been kind of in both uh
places at once and i've been thinking a
lot about what are the differences what
do i like about each style and so on and
you know industry is very versatile i
mean of course each university is
different as well but at least in
university
all universities have the same goal
which is to educate and to do excellent
academic research
in industry it's much more versatile
than that and the goals are not the same
so there are some companies where the
goal is really to just advance the state
of the art they have like basic research
labs and then in other companies the
goals may be different and they want
research that only kind of aligns with
the company's vision and maybe and very
specific subjects and so on and so forth
uh so i at microsoft research and
particularly my lab uh which is in uh in
boston um
there's actually a big support for a
kind of basic academic research and i
had 100 freedom to do whatever i want
and to do the research that you know i
think is important and i think you know
uh that was very valued um
so in that sense is academia the same
you know actually we do share the same
core values so is it the same and from
my
own opinion i think and actually
yesterday i talked about with abhishek
jain who gave me kind of a big kind of i
don't know
a thought that really inspired me which
is um
really the big difference
between
academia and
any kind of research lab
is that in academia we are parents of
the students
and you really sit with students and you
educate them and you work with them and
that kind of relationship and that kind
of energy of doing research with young
kind of uh students who are so eager and
so enthusiastic and so kind of their
eyes kind of pop up you know when they
do
this is really the big difference in my
opinion between academia and any kind of
uh research lab
um
so okay i'll end with that
hello everyone
my name is parikshit gopalan i'm
currently a researcher at apple i joined
about one month back
i've spent my entire career in industry
i was at microsoft research in silicon
valley until 2014 i was at microsoft
redmond for a year or so after that
i was at vmware until about a month ago
and actually when i got this very
generous invitation from shafi i was at
vmware
and but then i pulled a bait and switch
on them by the time it came to um you
know the actual event here i am at apple
so
because of this i actually didn't get
this email that shafi sent out it was
sent to my vmware address so i was
planning to come here and pretend i
don't know her questions but um you know
ravi reminded me of what they are so
anyway so i think a good starting point
um i'm going to follow up on what mike
luby said at the very start right about
we are all mortal beings doomed to die
you know uh
industry in industry you're especially
aware of this now just to do a thought
experiment
if we made a list of the top
universities 50 years ago
it's going to look just like
the list today
if we made a list of the top 50 industry
companies or industrial research labs 50
years ago
pretty sure none of the
none of the companies represented here
would be on that list right so this is
just you know this is where you start
from that things change
things change rapidly
so
and industries they have to be
constantly aware of this
and they have to be you know
ready for this change and in fact this
is one reason why a lot of companies do
invest in research they believe that
this is kind of the vanguard of change
and investing in research is our best
i won't say defense against this but you
know this is how we are going to be
leading this change rather than
succumbing to it
so
what does it mean to be
a theoretician in industry how is it
different from being in academia
in my view and this is completely my
personal view i'm not speaking for any
company or anybody else
i think the primary difference is it
comes from where you source your
problems right like
you come to i mean i come to a symposium
like this today
every talk is just amazing you could
spend your whole life just diving into
any one of these things
yet when you're in industry what is the
opportunity that you have right
there are all these
problems around you and the real world
is incredibly complex there's you know
you know there's people constantly
putting out fires systems are incredibly
complicated
there's not too many people with the
kind of training and background we have
where you look at something
and then you try and find the right
abstraction for it you try and think is
there something i have in my toolbox as
a theorist that i can bring to bear on
this is there a clean definition
waiting to be uh you know is there a
clean definition waiting to be made here
or something like that you know
so um
one criticism which is common
ingest of theorists is that we spend
days trying to optimize for constants in
our theories it's true we spend weeks
trying to find the right proofs and we
spend years trying to find the right
definitions i think this is the major
thing that we bring appropriately enough
for an area that started with the
definition right so
a lot of the really important
contributions historically whether it's
information or coding theory or more
recently with things like differential
privacy has been to take these very
impossible looking problems and try to
find nice clean formulations for them
this is ongoing work now whether it's
fairness correctness and machine
learning and so on
and being
a researcher in industry i think it
gives you an opportunity to be
very close to this aspect of it right in
some sense
we i think for the broader theory
community we serve this role as being
you know
we see where the rubber hits the road we
see the kinds of things that are
important and could benefit from a
theoretician's perspective
so
yeah in
in my sense that is what it means to be
a theorist in industry that's the
opportunity
that's what makes it exciting
how is it different it's the constant
change
great thank you
well i have a million questions but i
think to make it more interesting i'm
going to ask the audience if they have
questions if you don't i certainly have
a a bunch so if there's topics or
interest of of what you guys want to ask
please this is a good time to step up
um i wonder if any one of you has maybe
an example of where
something that was
very much thought to be few theoretical
actually had an impact
uh
okay sorry let's make this a serious
question right like i mean let me give a
serious answer to what is a serious
question
i mean i think this is
this is probably true of so many of the
ideas in theory right like i was at svc
in the early days of differential
privacy i mean there was just a lot of
skepticism
both internal and external about whether
there's anything really happening here
beyond people writing a lot of nice
papers and now you know you look at the
world around us that debate has been
definitively settled right so that's
just perhaps
one example where you know i think
sylvia was talking about examples um in
the context of consensus
the in fact if anything maybe we should
ask the opposite question of i'm sure
there are ideas which the moment you
write a paper everybody realizes that
this is a great thing and it goes and
changes the world that's rarely how
things happen i mean it would you would
be lucky
for things to happen that way but that's
really the exception to the rule not the
rule
right
i wanted to add to that that actually in
cryptography i think it's a huge success
story that a lot of the research that
has been done really purely theoretical
research is now being used all over the
place i mean cvo is one example but you
know even look at pcp's you know i
remember i was a student at mit and i
remember ellie vince's own working in
remember this discussion of but who will
ever use pcps isn't it frustrating to
work on this purely you know theoretical
thing that will never be used
and now look you know a
i know 15 20 years later so i i actually
agree with silvio what he said and what
you said in the talk which is
good ideas
find their views you know maybe not next
year maybe not 10 years maybe if you're
lucky 20 if you're less likely 50 but if
it's a good idea it will
you know
it's then it will be recognized
i think as in when quantum computers
become real that will be another great
answer to your question
yeah well those were actually uh it was
much more immediate right like um
i
i mean actually that i was going to use
that in an answer to another of shafi's
questions she asked is
basic research appreciated in industry
the paper that we wrote about these
things it's uh it's really a lower bond
but if there's one tried and tested
formula for success in coding theory
it's that you put a lower bond out there
and let people go and find matching
upper bounds they'll be doing this for
years after but
input
yes
thank you all for these great thoughts
so i had a question especially
connecting to what shanghai was also
saying yesterday um i think
uh
in some ways
like
some of the criticism of of the theory
community sometimes has been that we are
sort of inwards looking or as sometimes
phrase we get the good problems from the
people we respect
uh and
but we go back long enough at some point
somebody abstracted a question you were
trying to solve balance separator which
we recognize as a clean problem
was formulated to try to capture vsf
vlsi circuits uh and
all of you in the industry as you just
mentioned you're working close enough to
people really struggling
uh struggling trying to solve problems
and and you as as a theorist training
you can try to formulate an abstract
question you can say something useful
about
what could we do to increase
this kind of an exchange where where we
as a community have more exposure to
things
uh to questions people are looking for
better answers to
where where we could ground to source
new problems new interesting questions
that could
become relevant you know less than 50
years as as in silvio's
say 10 years right a decade a decade
would be a great timeline to go from
identifying a practical problem
formulating it giving something useful
that comes back a circle in a decade
i as far as i'm aware i think almost all
of the big
industry companies have programs for
interaction with academia i think there
are many opportunities to kind of write
together like a little proposal and to
start collaboration with
some researchers at the company at least
i can
talk for google because i'm involved
with some of these these programs but i
think many of the other companies have
similar
similar initiatives i think another
maybe avenue is that at least
in the area of privacy there is a lot of
kind of public discussion happening and
here i'll use the opportunity to plug in
something that i've been involved in and
i think it would benefit more eyes on it
which is kind of this effort to reinvent
the web
economic community and web advertising
where there's this public working group
which is called pat cg where essentially
all major companies that are represented
here sitting together and trying to
figure out
what is a good way to create new privacy
preserving
way to
organize uh this community and i think
there is like a
wealth of problems there that i don't
think we have even scratched the surface
of what can be solved and what will be
the different approaches and i think
these problems go way beyond computer
science and theoretical computer science
but if people are adventurous enough to
like want to look at and double in this
space i think uh i
one of my goals has been to encourage
more uh people from academia to kind of
participate in these communities and i
think that that goes to many uh other
problems and questions that there is
quite a public this discussions in many
of these areas and uh they give quite
nice opportunities for collaboration as
well
so i have a couple questions one is
actually after sylvia's talk umesh came
to me
and he said that you misunderstood his
question
he said that he it seemed you convinced
us
completely that there is no reason to do
anything different than what you guys
are doing in algorithm and certainly not
to do proofs of work and to do bitcoin
why isn't the whole world doing it so
this brings a bigger question and that
is sometimes we know
we know that the technology that a
company has let's say in digital
fountain or something it is much better
than what everybody else is doing and
yet it doesn't necessarily
conquer the world which tells you that
something
is i don't want to use profanities but
something is
wrong okay and uh
and and i mean i know this even from my
own experience i mean there is
technology and there's everything else
and technology does not
rule and i don't think it's a question
of practice or constance
it's something else which is where
industry i think i find it extremely
frustrating and i think it's related to
what sibling also said this morning
which was you know
didn't happen after year one didn't
happen after year two not five not 10
not 15 maybe 20 25 years
sometimes you know the world is just not
ready for a certain technology or it's
just not the right market or
applications out there and if that's
true it's just not going to happen
is the world
well that's a great question
world is ready for privacy
well i i actually i do think there's i
mean it seems like
50 60 of the people sitting up here
are working in privacy and big companies
so i don't think there's a there does
seem to be a focus on that
uh but sylvia you obviously want to say
something at least the best is uh i
don't know if it's a general topic but
um
but is a pointed question in my opinion
the world is ready for for for privacy
is a
certain
monopolistic industry who are not ready
for privacy and and therefore when
the public is not informed they'll all
be whatever it is if they're not
happening so right now we are in the
business in which a few companies and
figure out if we can get your data
and make you a slave and the private or
everything is relatable to yours and
sell it they can be profitable
privacy is absolutely their enemy if you
want to put back
vetting up we are the owner of our own
data and thank you very much i will sell
it to you if i want or if you want to
ask me for
thank you
so or if you want to ask do you want to
send me an advertisement i'll let you
know which subject i'm open to receiving
advertisement and here is an account in
which every time you want to advertise
to me you shall pay so that is so that i
think that the people won't they don't
even know if it's possible because
nobody going to to tell them this right
so you're going so
that is an issue that is a very much you
know
a political issue and somehow it is
right you know
they organized a
few but they have a very big um control
over society at large because they are
organized they have the money and you
don't and you have to go and say can you
give him a a subscription some year
later he's all that's what you what you
do are you competing with organized
amount of money but the world needs
privacy relevant sake so we are
privacy is really at the core of where
we are and so i but i don't think we can
blame you know industry i think they're
going to be a huge commercial advantage
for the first
uh if you really want to organize it
back a company that is going to start a
search engine on whatever it is done on
different principles and you shall see
that if you if you do it then when these
economics are going to change everybody
else if a lot better but
you know i really hoped i can fight with
silvio and kind of be against him so we
can have an interesting you know
conversation here but
i agree
didn't have to say this and uh well i it
does seem like we need a privacy
chernobyl for for this kind of change to
happen
i well we'll see it will if it will
happen or not but we maybe i mean the
the amount of data that uh companies
have on us and including variants
propolis
companies and governments is already
huge so but there might be so we are in
violent agreement
we only think we disagree research noble
has already happened and the point is
that we don't want to recognize it for
somehow we don't recognize it
so that vet is in my opinion so
whatever it was the last time
so many data disappearing you know
with whatever private but why do you
think that you know somehow and the fact
that you are enraged because they want
to send you
documents or things that are going to
make you even more enraged and more
ready to click on something is not an
english on your privacy don't win over
it i cannot even be on the web and i'm
gonna get the hedge immediately so i
think you know who is going to pay for
this emotional loss
so i mean this is happening we just
don't recognize it so
that's a that's a tragedy i don't think
we have to have enough to go farther
than that
some people are more sensitive to
radiation than others i guess
pays sex used to pay but it was a good
old time now rage pays even more which
apparently is the case and so and we are
actually bombarded by things that they
turn us one way or another and uh and
somebody benefits from it and and and
that why did this happen because of
violation of privacy because you know
exactly how to push my buttons
by sending an advertisement sending me a
mama a video sending me something and
vice versa and so somehow that is the
form visible but not classified
correctly by the public form of what is
the cost of an invasion of privacy you
have a split country a
you know aids and on a and vice versa
what else do we want what whatever cost
are we go what is the value of cost than
that it used to be united and no longer
are
so thanks to a few people who collect
money uh benefited from the always you
know
growing asia i think if this is not a
chernobyl for a measure of privacy i
don't know what it is
so just um
uh maybe to to not end with chernobyl um
uh interested in thoughts on how
how can industry and academia work best
together to advance science
so i i want to say something about that
uh i feel like uh recently there's much
more there are much more connections
actually between uh research and
academia there all of a sudden this idea
of doing kind of part-time i mean i
think it exists in the past but not i
think not as much as now i think a lot
of academics spend some time in industry
a lot of and i think the more we do it i
think also now especially is a great
time because somehow there's been so
much change in the past couple years uh
you know with covet and remote working
and all of a sudden everything is
possible people realize that you know
what we can we can
we don't have to stick into old habits
and i think if the the more kind of
connections the more kind of academics
spend the day a week two days or weeks
some kind of
the more this kind of space of research
will be fluid between academia and um
and industry i think we'll all gain from
it and you see it i see it in companies
i see it like in algorand you know you
have like amazing academics come
and work for a year for sabbatical uh
the more i think
this will exist the better our own
research will be especially because what
was said here i i agree that in academia
sometimes it's too easy
to publish papers with just with
which
simply improves the bound of the pre
previous paper not because necessarily
it's the interesting thing but you know
it's easy to get in because the people
who will review it are the ones who
pulled the previous bound and they
didn't solve it so they're they think
it's an important question so they'll
you know want
you know the so
you know what we really need is to ask
the right questions the interesting
questions and i think the more we think
like uh not we're not only in our own
little pond
you know kind of answering the question
that were posed in the previous you know
conferences
the more we'll be open and to new
notions new ideas new definitions and i
think we'll really benefit from it okay
can i can i uh engage with this real
quick um i'm really interested in this
point um because you know
my takeaway from the recent increase in
and the fluidity between um industry and
academia was the opposite
um which is that
often you know the sort of uh you know
intellectual spaces that academia had
carved out spaces of independence
and intellectual growth were sort of
undermined by industry objectives
and i didn't have the the sense that
this led to better questions this led to
a bunch of grad students
chasing uh you know okrs and industry
objectives and like cranking out models
instead of having brand new ideas you
know instead of discovering the next
generation of of something entirely new
right why do we think that industry is
uh providing disruptive inspiration to
uh our smartest minds why shouldn't they
look at uh
you know somewhere else uh you know the
other departments on campus for instance
right
and so i my experience at berkeley was
the opposite to be quite honest
on sorry this is a tag team question or
comment sorry uh we did discuss it
that's why um i also just wanted to um
tag on to that so um
i think it's you know perfectly okay
that there will be a group of people who
want to work in industry and
entrepreneurship and policy and whatever
it is and that
people get to sort of follow their bliss
in that way um for some of us you know
uh for me for instance right
i
recognize that a lot of industry is
profit driven i mean that's just what
what it's supposed to do and when you're
trying to maximize for profit that
creates perverse incentives that lead to
you know you discuss privacy there's a
whole bunch of other issues that happen
as well and so my research is concerned
with those perverse incentives right and
and the harms that they cause to real
people and especially marginalized
groups of people and in my sort of
extremely brief experience with industry
and this was at microsoft research which
i think is sort of as close to academia
as it gets as people say i felt like
that was not a space where i could do
that research at all um i actually sort
of ended up uh pulling out of an
internship at google that
that uh
before i did it because i just felt like
it just i couldn't do the work that i do
with the integrity that it deserves in
industry and in academia i found that um
i i'm still kind of feeling uh infringed
actually right
i'm not sort of able to have the
independence um to do the research that
i do because at the end of the day many
of my colleagues do spend time in
industry many of my colleagues are still
driven by industry objectives
a lot of people split their time sort of
a lot of the work that i do that's not
necessarily
sort of benefiting industry is sort of
seen sometimes is not valuable because
it's trying to benefit something else
right and so i
you know i recognize that for some
people this industry connection might be
positive but for for some people for
those of us for whom it's not a positive
connection what can industry do and what
can academics do to protect the sort of
uh the the space that needs to be carved
out and protected away from industry so
that we can do the research that we do
with some integrity
that's a great point and you did bring
up another great point which is uh it's
a huge difference between academia and
industry industry is is not just
partially driven by profit but
completely driven by profit
and so that does and and so i it raises
another question is where do the great
ideas for
other sort of things come from do they
really come from industry
maybe not so much right so maybe
many of the main great ideas actually
come out of academia and some of them
grow into companies some grow to other
things
so that's another thing i kind of wanted
to kind of get you guys his opinion on
but maybe you can react to this first
yeah yeah i i guess i want to react to
your your point uh and also touch upon
that upon what you said mike which is uh
uh
that is very unfortunate you know i
completely agree when i say you know you
can benefit from from industry what i
mean is you can benefit from thinking
about real world problems
that's kind of what my point was that
sometimes it's too comfortable in
academia to ask the wrong question it's
just because it's our comfort it's so
easy and it's so
so when you look at industry you get
kind of more of like what does the real
world mean right now yes you're right
that it's
profit driven but that's kind of
what's profitable in some sense not
always not always i agree for example
the privacy issue right where people try
to stream you with with junk uh you know
advertisement but um but often or at
least sometimes
what gives you profit is what the world
needs that was profitable and these
questions you see
[Music]
you want to take a poll
all right
who disagrees with you
okay so maybe maybe uh i would like to
add something to me
it has always felt that uh
also
academics are kind of
keeping industry honest to some extent
in the sense that there are many attack
papers rights that come out of academia
that they're looking at
products or like practices in industry
that
are pinpointing issues with them
and
i don't think they're always accepted in
a negative way right this is something
that is keeping people in industry
honest and in most cases
these things are trying to be taken
seriously and are trying to be addressed
in some way maybe there is no direct way
immediately but i i do think this kind
of interaction is also kind of
constructive and helps
industry improve and kind of
create some healthy interaction
and
i also agree that there are some
interesting problems coming from
industry and there are things that are
sits completely separately and there's
space for both of them and
i think trying to respect and understand
this is kind of the core of the
interaction that doesn't always have to
be necessarily work on the same problem
so maybe another thing to i there's a
lot of it's great there's so much
before i thought of it was that no
that's great
sorry i want to
pick up an important sure point for our
friend uh of a very
extreme
and
we are divided up in
institutions right even in academia that
they are
pretty much similar to one another and
so therefore if you don't like a you can
go to a prime minister it's not a b or c
this is another one they're all equal
and so
ideally you would like to have some more
diversity but there are some university
that applies to the same rule of third
and and independence epidemic but you
can actually pick and choose the one
that is close to you we don't have that
somehow to a larger stand so what i
wonder is uh however given um
our ability to
coalesce around the december idea and
even
through donation investments or whatever
you call it to try to put
money into something which is more that
we like but we can actually create some
hybrid structure later but i believe
before the current technology and
communication technology and things so
we could not even find each other but i
think that uh
i would like to know to have in a
different type of university which are
different or
objectives and then people can actually
flow where they where they go but to be
i don't have a recipe but i think i
recognize the problem and so very often
and i believe that
diversity in our gene pool diversity in
in our
decentralization i would say from the
standpoint
of the industry that i now represent is
a good thing and so somehow for what
there is a lot of homogeneity in the
social society which i don't believe is
to our benefit and both in an industry
in academia and if you can try to solve
it it's just an observation i have no
recipe right but i think you have a a a
good point you're making a good point
yeah i think
no no it's right here
i'm joking shopping to not be with them
like i was just saying that i agree with
you i think it would be nice to have a
variety of institutions and right now we
don't have that and for me you know when
i i started my career not that long ago
and for me there's a big difference
between in my mind at least a big
difference between public and private
institutions uh public institutions are
meant to serve the public i mean they
have a very different mandate than uh
private institutions um and it's not to
excuse private institutions but i felt
like uh you know being here at berkeley
an institution that i love very much uh
to see the level of privatization of
things that is happening within this
institution has been really um hard for
me to kind of uh to grapple with right
so i think that one of the things that
we could do as an academic community is
to think critically about how we can
better protect public institutions at
least and then kind of uh take it from
there so i appreciate what you're saying
right so so i think one point uh i also
like to get your feedback
which i um
let me remove this right uh uh
to a large degree connect to some of
those points is that
you know i don't want to reveal my age
but when i
was a phd student at cmu i happened to
took the last class of
regression
at that time when taught that the class
he went microsoft and as a student at
that time we think it's nuts right but
but that's because at that junction in
the night uh late 80s or early 90s
we always have this image that the
academic is somehow the cutting edge
but then as a times goes on in computing
i think it is more and more sense that a
lot of the type of work
academic is no longer in the cutting
edge the industry
as a institution
uh
contain a lot of cutting edge right so i
think it is changing our dynamic can
really
uh you know create an interesting new
balance in
between the role between academic and
industry so i don't know in long term
you know how this dynamic will go it's
only because our current computer
science is in rising so clearly
this is the moment industry is driving
uh
i mean for theories completely slightly
differently we can still improve on the
previous read out for you then
well i think that's you know it's um
it's very dependent on what you're
talking about right like for areas
within theory like if you're working on
say the unique games conjecture or
analysis of boolean functions i mean
these are very
core scientific areas and it's something
that a community needs to invest in and
obviously industry is not the place
where the cutting edge for this happens
right so it's um it's a bit more nuanced
to it i don't think it's just one way or
the other it depends on what area
i still don't know if you could say
most of the cutting i mean it's it's uh
you know
it's a balance i think still right
so i want to add to uh what pariksha is
saying i think it really depends on the
area even the 90s or 80s it's still the
case that if you look at some other
topic like sevilla sci fabrication
probably industry was still the leader
right not academy academia
so it i think depends on the topic and
now machine learning is really vogue and
therefore we get a feel that okay all
the cutting edge work happens in
industry but it's
it's a bit more different than that
so i have a question so obviously as a
as people working in industry you don't
have the same protections that say
people
in the university you don't have tenure
same protections of academic freedom but
do you feel like you have some kind of a
duty
as academics to keep some say red lines
in term of like say
if you're asked
not to publish a paper or to modify your
paper because of
company
it's not positive for the company's
image or something like that is that a
red line or
do you think it's
there are kind of limitations
that you need to protect
all right another question along that
line are there things that you don't
publish just because the company wants
to keep it secret until they kind of
take advantage of it so to speak
yes
yes maybe i completely understand this
is different
okay
well there are many answers here you
know
so
we want to attract a certain
type of people okay that we're uniquely
qualified to advance you know and this
type of people i'm not going to be
stopped by no published paper so if you
really want to attract those people you
let them publish whatever you want and
you're better off that we are you know
just a a coffee cup a wave and not
justin or somewhere else altogether so i
am so absolutely
the reason or
uh i understand that there is a
legitimate
um need for some people to to give it
but you know
at least
in in in a startup or in a right startup
i think that's you know you is a
counterproductive
for me would totally be a red line for
sure
in my experience like i've never had a
single instance where my paper was
blocked saying that we cannot publish it
because it's going to make us look bad
so i think the number of instances of
such things are very rare i believe
and uh also i never rented but certainly
being a theoretician helps with this
like
[Laughter]
it's just uh
but i
i
that's a good point um
right uh
that is true being being uh sort of on
the inside side of the industry in
general i
cannot criticize
my company or any other company in fact
just because it's i cannot say that
google is not private whether i believe
this or not
it's just yes there are some limitations
i did not personally have to ever run
into this in my publications
because that's my publications are
mostly uh theoretical
but uh
it it is
uh i again i didn't run into this but i
can certainly imagine some people and
there have been instances and i maybe
some people will want other other people
not on the panel who want to share their
experience
uh that that certainly can exist and
could be a
red line for some people
so like vitaly i'm not allowed to
criticize other companies but i think i
can say good things about other
companies so let me tell you my
experience when we were in azure right
like so we um
came up with these codes and then we
wanted to write a paper about it we were
expecting that there would be some
extent of you know
don't give the secret sauce away kind of
thing but ins instead
they're very happy to publish everything
explicit you want to implement this code
yourself go read the paper we tell you
what coefficients or what finite field
to use and we were somewhat surprised by
this we asked like aren't you worried
that you're giving the crown jewels away
they were
no what we want is mind share we want
people to know that you know we have
cool stuff and you know we want so the
way people think about these is nuanced
it's not as simple as you know one might
think this of course bases the
possibility that other people would just
read what you did and copy it and we
know instances we think where that
happened but you know it's part of the
risk you take
so i actually wanted to go back to one
point that was raised before which is
this sort of who's driving the agenda is
it the in the industry or is it the
academia in terms of driving the
research agenda i think it's something
that was brought up earlier and and
that's something that i kind of wanted
to it seems like i'm hearing that maybe
the the industry is driving the agenda a
little bit maintenance the people say so
i'm uh
i'm not sure the agenda is driven by
whatever drives it well that's another
question i wanted to raise and that's
i'm just curious like everybody's sort
of thinking oh i'm going to go work in
some company or whatever but another
avenue is to do what you did silvio for
example is go and start a company so
that's another avenue if you're really
sort of
you know
really excited about something in some
new area that you really want to get out
there and it's got some some legs to it
then you go and start your own company
and that's the best way to kind of get
stuff out there i think
it's difficult
but i want to say i think if a company
takes researchers and tells them what to
work on it's stupid like they wound it's
like cutting
that's
then don't take researchers that's not a
researcher's job a researcher's job is
you know you're open-minded and you come
up with ideas you can't
it's
so counterproductive right but we did
hear earlier that there was a lot of
industry sort of driving the agenda of
what's going on in the academic world
right
i i think it's it's not so like
narrow that the industry tells you this
is exactly the problem i think it broads
like it's a broader stroke so like okay
where are the interesting things what
are we struggling with like uh
and i think from that point on i think
academics in my experience like right we
have these grants that people take them
and like go and do all kinds of other
interesting things that may or may not
be remotely connected to what was the
initial motivation for the problem and
i think also my experience as a
researcher
in industry is like nobody comes to tell
me what what to do right it's my job to
like look around me and figure out where
what i am good at
can be can be used or what what kind of
problems i will formulate for myself
yeah i i see that but i've seen also
there's been
problems with that i mean there's
there's there's been examples where
that's grown to a certain point like a
ntt right where it became so independent
and so divorced from the company at some
point
the hammer comes down and they they slam
the whole thing i know the same thing
happened at some portions of microsoft
at some point right and ibm and other
places right so there is this tricky
kind of trade-off there it's not so
straightforward
personally i don't find it offensive of
it if one interest is a i'm opening
research in this subject and if you're
interested in another subject right come
here spend five years as long as you're
interested when you're interested you
move with some somewhere else which is
more interested but is okay but i wanted
to say that another wrinkle i want to
put but in all this you know research
versus industry
we are doing extremely well and our
society is so dynamic and
just because we have invested a society
an insane amount of money into public
education we thought of this you know if
it
really started programmatically the new
national state 100 years ago
there would be no academia there would
be
some one two three four academic places
uh repeating uh theology or whatever
we're doing you know for uh for years on
end so
it really bubbling
so the debate in my opinion is when
also radiant was talking about public or
or private sometimes you know i come
from a different tradition writing which
is a most of a research is done in a
public institution let me tell you
there is no tenure there you are tenure
the moment you get in you can get in on
a demands position and then another
advancement
and there are some benefits and there
are some negativity certainly have a lot
of
independence but then the negative is
better to work with
national competition before anybody
rather than you know in a private
university you can iron the spot very
quickly very efficiently so you lose
people um
abroad
or to a private
university just because you cannot so
nimble in reacting
but um i really think of it you know we
have to be more prepared and christos
here at the uh
idea about the water
what do we are trying to optimize for uh
genes and and things so i think we want
to do
not immediately improving things but to
have enough resist resilient apparatus
for whatever
changes might come i really believe that
by the way we don't invest
enough in public education
so i am in in this country great country
of ours which has many benefits but also
many things were
not exactly optimized
so all um
middle school
high schools are really local they are
funded with local money if you are in a
poor neighborhood you get poorly paid
teacher
is this a way we optimize is it hard to
me to believe what the hell are we
optimizing there is no way to do it so
whether it is interesting things is is
the same narrow silos so that they don't
come up so i think we are better off
just to have you know
um
sally on a national basis and
get you know great teachers be
everywhere and you get everybody
because at the end you know we are doing
minutiae industry academia the thing you
know the real thing is that the larger
part of our countrymen is not as
educated as they could be
and that's a problem it's a problem
because it doesn't there's not enough
idea coming up so pretty soon we're
going to pay a price you know 50 000
years from now oh that's a good point i
i have a big question asked who's
keeping the time here
nobody is
i think we're in trouble then
so it's kind of getting late i think we
should probably wrap it up
uh anybody want to have any last
thoughts or comments
i have one quick quick thing to say as a
remarks what have you said before which
is that's exactly why i think fluidity
is so important because um
you know because exactly you want people
to come to your company and do what they
want to do so if today they're
interested in consensus they should come
today if they marry their tuna they
should leave that's why you want the
fluidity people to come for six months
while they're interested then they leave
then that's how i think the model should
be yeah
hazak
okay great thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you all for making the event a
spectacular success i hope to see